Luke here the outer Boys YouTube channel
and I'm back at my Alaskan Homestead a
couple months ago I bought this
abandoned Homestead looking for some
adventure and boy did we find it we
found thousands of dollars of abandoned
equipment we've had cabins catch on fire
equipment's been breaking down and we've
been breaking our backs building a road
through the swamp I'm spending almost a
week working on projects here at the
homestead and I'm bringing you guys
along for the ride
[Music]
well the weather forecast said this week
was going to be clear and sunny
we got this instead but I've ordered
thousands of dollars of gravel and heavy
equipment to come fix this Trail and
there's no turning back now
we're gonna have to make this happen
[Music]
[Applause]
some neighbors saw me struggling to move
all this gravel and came to help out
yeah it's gonna be a big help all right
one mud puddle down many more to go
[Music]
foreign
every time one of these trucks drops a
load that cost me about 320 dollars
we got a lot done in one day there's
about 14 truckloads of dirt that's about
168 cubic yards we're about a third of
the way done
good
nice and rainy
got a new generator
this time I'm storing it outside of
course I brought fire extinguishers
for those of you who haven't been
watching my videos I bought this a few
months ago and it was just full of
abandoned equipment ATVs wood splitters
generators unfortunately we've had some
issues my 9000 watt generator caught on
fire and nearly burned this cabin down
so high on my agenda today is to get
that generator hooked up and get our
electrical system back to the way it was
yeah
I left the keys to the cabin back at the
house
oh
look at that
it's not how the lock should work but
I'm grateful
oh my goodness
what the heck
I could break the lock but honestly
repairing it just sounds like a lot of
work
foreign
Starbucks
okay I'm pretty sure at this point thank
you so much that was delicious
that was such a lovely meal it's a lot
easier to deal with things but you got
food in your stomach it's been a long
day and I've got a long way to go to get
home before midnight so I'm gonna put up
the camera and I will see you guys in
the morning
thank you
all right
something's wrong with my system my
batteries are completely dead supposedly
this inverter prevents that from
happening it shuts the system down
before the batteries get all the way to
zero so
something's wrong with this box that it
allowed that to happen
oh boy if I'm going to diagnose the
problem with the electrical system I've
got to get the batteries Juiced up the
batteries are so dead the inverter can't
even recognize them and so I can't even
charge the batteries the way they are
I'm not quite sure what I'm going to do
to fix that
but the main thing I wanted to do today
was to get some propane
that's why propane fittings are made out
of brass brass doesn't Spark
s
[Applause]
[Music]
all right
got probably a Year's worth of propane
in there
shouldn't have to do that again for a
while I'd really like to have some
electricity in the cabin tonight I
brought this generator along but there's
a problem so this is the old outlet that
the generator used to plug into and you
can see here it's not a normal 120 volt
Outlet this generator only plugs into
120 volt Outlets this is the cable the
old generator used to run power into the
house but you can see here it's melted
on one end so we have got to do some
splicing but if my memory serves me
correctly a 120 volt head only uses
these three wires
foreign
well there we go hopefully it won't
start another cabin fire here choke it
light
well it took some doing but we got
electricity for tonight
it's a little bit cold I'm gonna get the
fire started
uh smoke detector up there is beeping
all right let's see
all right there we go
yeah we got firework extinguishers
definitely want to have more of those
let's see if we got propane
yeah we got propane
you know some curry rice sounds pretty
good to me
okay this might sound a little stupid
but I just noticed that there's a
propane heater right there I have no
idea if this thing works or not
oh oh my goodness that is putting out
the heat that's a really pleasant
surprise as much as I love wood stoves
getting up in the middle of the night to
feed them is not fun
that natural gas stove I can keep this
place warm all night long
uh oh
oh the generator just switched off last
time I had a generator turn off on me my
cabin was on fire
just ran out of gas that being said that
presents a bigger problem
I'm burning up a lot of fuel just to
turn on a light the batteries were fixed
I could run the generator for two three
hours and then run the cabin off the
batteries for two days without the
batteries I've got to run the generator
anytime I want electricity so just
turning on a light requires me to burn
up a lot of gas
all right some hot chocolate Japanese
Curry not too bad
here's the Honda my generator app on my
phone and I just go and hold this down
and there we go the generator's off all
right guys it's late I'm going to bed
got a lot of work to do in the morning
all right I'll see you guys then
[Music]
ah there we go
got some pancake mix
okay
that filled me up
all right guys I've got gravel trucks
coming I've got to go about a mile or so
down the trail and meet him
foreign
[Music]
that's pretty impressive
the trucks are having to back up about
half a mile down this tiny little Trail
in Reverse it's crazy but also that
means I've got to walk a half a mile in
and then a half a mile out to guide each
truck it's getting a bit much I'm
getting my steps in today so I grabbed
something that might help me with this
problem
oh
I got this thing brand new for about 800
bucks
you know the reason why I'm having to
dump so much gravel on this Trail is
because every time I bring a truck in
I'm damaging the trail so I'm having to
repair the trail as we bring in the dirt
this is a section of the trail we built
up the other day and you can see after
six loads by the big trucks there's
already a one foot deep rut so it's
gonna take a couple truckloads to repair
the damage we did into this section of
trail that wasn't damaged previously
we're fixing things only slightly faster
than we're breaking them
if we had a couple weeks of dry weather
I could have done this with half the
gravel I used because this sort of thing
wouldn't be happening but it's fall here
in Alaska and that means it's going to
rain right until it starts to snow
stockpile gravel and take it one bucket
load at a time further down the trail
this is only about a third the way to my
cabin
all right we're gonna be just laying
down gravel 10 feet at a time
it's gonna be a long process
well we've run into a little bit of a
snag from here on out the trail gets a
lot smaller and the ground is very soft
look how jiggly that is and that backhoe
is just too heavy it's tearing up the
trail so from here on out we've got to
use the track the Bobcat but we have
another 50 to 60 cubic yards of gravel
that we need to haul somewhere around
120 trips with the Bobcat so I've worked
out a deal with my neighbor and he's
going to help me hopefully this rain
will ease up so we don't tear up the
trail running that skid steer back and
forth
nope it's Alaska
oh take this thing back to the cabin
[Music]
now I need to just do that 119 times
more
ah but before I start putting gravel on
this stuff I need to get it prepped a
little bit more there's a few places
like this where I could use an extra log
or two
and I should put a plastic Fabric or
something over the top to keep the rocks
from getting pushed down into the mud
you know before I do all that though I
need to get some dinner I'm hungry
all right
[Music]
foreign
I've got so much work yet to do but it's
getting late I think I need to put up
the Chainsaw for tonight
I'm gonna get some water
[Music]
there's a lot of people in this part of
Alaska who don't have wells so this is a
drinking station
all right
these are bear proof handles
for a lot of people in this community
every drop of water they use has to be
taken from that watering station and
hauled and jugs back to their cabin over
ATV trails really makes you appreciate
water
[Applause]
thank you
oh my goodness I am sore but we got a
lot done the next day
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Applause]
the first load of many
[Music]
we're covering about five to six linear
feet with each load and it's taking
about 30 minutes round trip so we're
moving about 10 to 12 feet per hour
ah
[Music]
foreign
roll down two to go
see how things are going on the other
end
hey things are moving along right on
schedule
that means you're going better than
expected
[Applause]
all right
oh there goes my tripod I think I smoked
my tripod on that one
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
I found a bunch of junk that the
previous owner had thrown into a mud
hole to try to drive over it might as
well reuse it right
no
the guys it's getting late I think I
need to call it for this trip but it's
not the end of the video
we're gonna finish this
look at that
is pretty awesome
thank you
can't tell you how good it feels to see
Rock going down on my trail just so much
left to do
first
problem of the day
I have locked myself out again my only
set of cabin Keys fell off my Carabiner
yesterday and I lost them
aha
use this old deer stand and see if we
can't build a ladder
oh there we go I am graceful
[Music]
tada
okie doke now I'm going to show you a
little trick for picking up a padlock
first on agenda we've got to finish that
trail oh
all right I just got a really bad phone
call from the owner of the gravel
company apparently the truck driver that
was delivering our gravel this morning
hit a bad patch on the trail the nearest
they're willing to deliver the gravel is
at the road system which would be almost
an additional one mile round trip for
the Bobcat that would mean it would take
one hour to take one scoop of gravel
from the stockpile to my property and
all that time energy and money I spent
placing gravel was just so we could get
the trucks closer to my property and now
they're not willing to do it so
um I need to go hop on the bike and
inspect the trail and see what this
truck driver is talking about and see
whether it's something we can fix
my neighbor just told me the truck
driver got kind of stuck right here in
this spot and he ended up just having to
dump his load and get out of here so
oh we're not getting any more gravel for
today I think we're gonna have to get
ourselves a smaller dump truck and use
it to shuttle from the beginning of the
trail to the middle of the trail and
then the Bobcat will take it from there
onto my property but we're at a
standstill we're not getting any more
dirt laid down today
I've got a lot of things I'm stressing
about but I have got to focus on this
I've got to get this Trail Ready for
gravel before I leave today
foreign
[Applause]
now I just need a whole lot of rocks it
is late and I think I need to get headed
home I've lost count of how many days
I've been working on this project
but look at that
Blue Sky haven't seen that in a little
while
oh this is a survey marker for the
property corner
I was told this was the property corner
right there
that's the property corner right there
then it means my property Cuts right
through this road
for Mike here over is on my neighbor's
property
I'll see you guys next video I gotta
think about this
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor Boys YouTube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this and don't forget to click
subscribe so you can see other great
videos every Saturday morning hit that
Bell button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching